تقدم طالبان بوعود كثيرة
يمكن للفتيات الذهاب إلى المدرسة ولن نصبح
ملاذًا
للإرهابيين وقال الرئيس بايدن بثقة هذا الصباح أه
أن أفغانستان لن تعود إلى
ما كانت عليه قبل 20 عامًا ولكن لماذا
نعتقد أن هناك
مقاتلو القاعدة الذين يقاتلون في الخطوط الأمامية
إلى جانب طالبان في هذا
يجب أن نعتقد أنه يجب علينا الانتظار ونرى
ما سيحدث بالفعل وبالمناسبة
أعتقد أنهم سيكونون في
مأزق غير عادي ، كان
لدى الحكومة الأفغانية عمومًا
ميزانية قدرها  حوالي 19 مليار دولار أو ما يقرب من ذلك ،
معظمها قدمتها
اليابان الأمريكية وبعض الدول المانحة الرئيسية الأخرى
أه هم على وشك مواجهة
عجز بنحو 17 أو 18 مليار دولار حتى
استكماله
بعائدات تجارة المخدرات غير المشروعة
التي سيطرت عليهم  لسنوات عديدة ،
فإن نبات الخشخاش ومنتجاته
والخدمات الأساسية ستؤدي إلى تدهور
الرواتب ولن يتم دفعها ،
وسيتراجع الاقتصاد وفي
مرحلة ما
سوف يرون الأضواء
تنطفئ ليس فقط في كابول ولكن في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، ماذا يحدث إذن كيف
يتفاعل طالبان
، ثم يأتون إلى
المجتمع الدولي ويقولون أنك تعرف ربما نريد
اتباع نهج مختلف ، لذا مرة أخرى
أعتقد أنه من السابق لأوانه أن تبدأ في فعل
أي شيء أكثر من مجرد التفكير في أنك
يجب أن تفكر دائمًا في كل
بديل ، وأعتقد أن هذا قد أظهر أنه
يجب أن تكون مبدعًا للغاية بشأن
البدائل وما يمكن أن
يحدث